[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCOIS CHOLLET: Hi, everyone.
I'm Francois, and
I'll be telling you
about the integration of the
Keras API into TensorFlow.
So first of all, what is Keras?
If you know about
TensorFlow, you probably
also know about Keras,
but just in case,
for those who don't know.
Keras is an API that makes
building deep-learning models
easier and faster.
So it's a deep-learning toolbox,
and it's all about ease of use,
reducing complexity,
reducing cognitive load.
And if you make deep learning
easier to use, what happens
is that you're also making
it accessible to more people.
So the key idea with Keras
is to put deep learning
into the hands of everyone.
We believe that, in the
future, deep learning
will be part of every
developer's toolbox.
It will not just be a tool
for experts and researchers.
It will be into
everyone's hands.
And this will happen with
platforms like TensorFlow
and APIs like Keras.
So Keras is better
understood not as a library
or as a code base.
It's more of an API spec.
And it's an API spec that
has several different
implementations.
There's the Theano
implementations,
which was the original
Keras [AUDIO OUT] released
two years ago.
There's a TensorFlow
implementation, of course.
And then there will be more
implementations in the future.
For instance, Microsoft is
working on a [INAUDIBLE]
implementation of Keras.
And so until now, the
TensorFlow implementation
separates [INAUDIBLE]
with lots of uses.
And what we are doing now is
that we are bringing the Keras
API directly into
the Keras project,
into the TensorFlow project.
We believe that's a
big step towards making
TensorFlow and deep learning
accessible to everyone.
So what's concretely
happening is
that we are bringing into
TensorFlow this Keras
compatibility module,
tf.keras, which
is an implementation
of the Keras spec
that's built from the
ground up for TensorFlow.
And so as part of
this move, we're
introducing into core
TensorFlow new data structures
like layers, which
Martin just introduced.
And also models,
which are containers
for graphs of layers.
So these used to be
Keras data structures,
and now they will be shared
between core TensorFlow
and this tf.keras module.
So, because this
Keras implementation
is built from the
ground up on top
of the shell of
the structures, it
is fully compatible with all of
the TensorFlow functionality.
That means it's also compatible
with [AUDIO OUT] features that
has the experiment API
that Martin introduced.
So if you're a Keras user,
here's what this means for you.
First, it gives you access
to more flexibility.
You become able to very
easily mix and match
pure TensorFlow functionality
with Keras functionality.
So you can build more
powerful, more flexible models.
And what's more, you gain
access to really advanced,
really powerful features
through the [INAUDIBLE]
TensorFlow training API
that Martin mentioned.
You gain access to very quick
and easy distributed training
for Keras models.
You gain access to training
on Cloud ML, distributed
hyperparameter training, which
is really, really powerful,
and you can very easily
deploy your Keras modules
to production with
TensorFlow serving.
If you're a
TensorFlow user, what
does this change mean to you?
Basically, it gives you access
to the full scope of the Keras
API to make your life
easier without leaving
your existing
TensorFlow workflow.
So you can just start
using the Keras API
at no loss of flexibility.
You don't have to
adopt all of Keras,
you can just adopt the layers
you need, for instance.
And also, it gives you
access to any existing piece
of open source Keras code.
You can just go on GitHub,
copy some piece of Keras code,
drop it into your codebase,
and, by just changing imports,
it will just work.
So this gives you access to
a lot of existing open source
code that you can start
leveraging into your TensorFlow
workflow.
So to make things a
bit more concrete,
I will walk you
through an example
of what your workflow will
look like when using Keras
with TensorFlow.
And we'll be looking at a
video question answering model,
and we'll be using
Keras to define a model
to solve this
problem, and we will
retrain it using the
high-level TensorFlow training
API in a distributed setting.
So this is a problem
that we'll be looking at.
We have some videos, which
are sampled about four frames
per second, roughly
10 seconds per video,
so we have about 40
frames per video.
And we are asking
questions about the video,
about what's going on in the
video, and about the contents.
Here we have this video
of a woman packing objects
into a car.
You can ask, what
is the woman doing?
What's the color of her shirt?
And the answer should
be a single word.
So we'll build a
deep-learning model
that it will take as inputs the
video as a sequence of frames,
so about 40 frames in
order, and the question,
and the model should output
one word, the answer.
And so if you ask this question,
what is the woman doing?
She's packing.
It's actually interesting
because, if you only
take one frame and try
to train a [INAUDIBLE],
for instance, to
answer the question,
the problem is that
just from one frame,
she could also be
unpacking as well, right?
And the reason you know
she's actually packing
is because of the
order of the frames.
If you look at the second frame,
the rug is outside the car.
In the next frame,
it's inside the car.
And so we expect all
the planning model
to be able to leverage this
order to correctly answer
this type of question.
So needless to say, this is a
tremendously difficult problem.
And just a few years
ago, three or four years
ago before TensorFlow,
before Keras,
this would only have been
accessible to a handful
of large companies or in very
well-funded research labs,
especially if you wanted
to make your model
train on a cluster of GPUs.
And now with TensorFlow
as a platform
and with Keras as
an API, we're making
these three difficult
problems accessible to anyone
with just basic [INAUDIBLE]
scripting capabilities.
So we are putting the full
power of deep learning
into the hands of everyone.
So here's a model that you
would use to solve this problem.
At the high level,
it has two branches.
There's one branch that's meant
to encode the video inputs
into a single vector
and one branch meant
to encode the question,
so a sequence of words,
into a single vector.
So we have one vector,
including information
about the entire
video, one vector,
including information
about the entire question.
And then we concatenate
these two vectors.
And this gives us
one single vector
that encodes information
about the entire problem,
about the combination of
the video and the question.
And that's kind of the beauty
and the magic of deep learning
is that you take perceptual
inputs, like a video,
for instance, you
take semantic meaning,
and you're embedding this
perceptual input [AUDIO OUT]
And you're embedding this
meaning into geometric space.
You're turning
meaning into vectors
and then you can learn
interesting transformations
of these geometric spaces.
So that's really the
beauty of deep learning.
And so in our case, we'll
be taking this vector
and coding the entire problem.
And we will be training a fully
connected [INAUDIBLE] on top.
And it will end
up with a softmax
over a predefined
vocabulary, and so the word
with the highest probability
in this vocabulary
will be the answer
to the question.
So now if you want to look
at a higher level of detail,
how do we turn a video
into a single vector?
How do we turn a
question into a vector?
So for the video, we're
starting out with the video
as a sequence of frames.
So each frame is just an image.
So it's RGB, it has a height,
a width, a depth, color depths.
The other sequence
of frame, you use
a [INAUDIBLE] to transform each
frame into a single vector.
So essentially you're
using the conditional base
of a pre-trained
network, and you
do some pulling to
extract one vector that
encodes the visual
contents of the frame.
And so what you get out
of this is the video
anchored as a
sequence of vectors,
where each vector encodes the
visual contents of one frame.
And then you take the sequence
and you run it through an LSTM.
So you probably know
what an LSTM is,
but basically it's a
[INAUDIBLE] type of network
that can process sequences
and takes into account order.
And this LSTM will output
a single vector encoding
information about
the entire video.
To turn a question
into a vector,
we are following a
very similar process.
We represent a
question as a sequence
of integers, each integer
standing for a word.
And then we map each
word to a word vector
via a process called embedding.
So we get out of this a
sequence of word expressed
as a sequence of vectors.
We run it through
a different LSTM
layer, which will encode
the entire question
as a single vector.
So in Keras, here's
the architecture
that we would use to
implement this model,
and it's literally just
a very simple translation
of the previous graph.
So for the video
encoder, basically, we
are starting from the
video as a 5D tensor.
The first axis will
be the batch axis.
Then you have the time axis.
Then you have a 3D tensor,
which encodes a frame.
And so we will apply an
Inception v3 network,
pre-trained on ImageNet to
every frame of the 5D tensor
to extract one vector, one
feature vector, per frame.
And so out of this,
we get a sequence
of visual vectors, which will
run through an LSTM layer.
And for the question
embedding part,
we are simply using an embedding
layer to map our question.
So a sequence of integers
into a sequence of vectors,
and we run that
through an LSTM layer.
Finally, we use a
concat operation
to bring together
these two vectors,
and we stack a few dense layers.
And we end up with a softmax
over a predefined vocabulary.
And you are training that with
a target answer word encoded
as a one-hot vector.
So what does
implementation look like?
It's very simple.
What you're seeing here
is the video encoder
in just five lines.
During the first
line, you're just
specifying the shape
of your video input.
So it's a 5D tensor.
With a shape argument,
you do not actually
specify the batch size.
So the first axis, set
to none, is a time axis.
So it's set to none because
we want it to be viable.
We want the small one
to be able to process
videos of any number of frames.
And then you have the
shape of a single frame.
So a single frame is
150 by 150 RGB image,
so it's a tensor
that's 150, 150 by 3.
In the next line,
what we are doing
in a single line
is instantiating
an Inception v3 network
that will automatically
load pre-trained weights,
so train on ImageNet.
And we'll configure this network
to be doing visual feature
extraction.
So essentially we'll
not be including
the classifier part
of Inception v3,
only in the convolutional base.
And then we'll be applying
some average pulling
on top of the bottleneck layer.
You just extract one single
vector, bare image input.
Then this next line, we
are setting [INAUDIBLE]
to be non-trainable.
So what this means is
that, during training,
we will not be
updating the weights.
And why?
Simply because it's
a pre-trained model.
And if you were to update
its weights while training
on this new problem
of question answering,
we will likely be wrecking
the representations
that this model has already
learned on ImageNet.
So you don't want to do that.
You just freeze it.
And so the next step is to
use a time-distributed layer
to essentially take
this [INAUDIBLE]
and apply it to every
step of the time
axis of the video input.
So this time-distributed layer
just takes this [INAUDIBLE]
and apply it to every frame.
And what comes out of
this layer is simply
3D tensor, which is a
sequence of visual frames,
a sequence of visual vectors.
So each vector is
standing for one frame.
And finally, we run
this sequence tensor
through an LSTM layer, and
this gives us one single vector
encoding a [INAUDIBLE] video.
And as you can notice, when we
are instantiating this Keras
LSTM layer, we only
specify one parameter,
which is the number of
units in the LSTM layer.
And if you think about it,
that's quite remarkable,
because there are so many
advanced configuration
parameters in this LSTM layer.
There are a lot of
these practices you have
to follow when using LSTMs.
For instance, you
have to remember
that your record on weights
should be initialized using
[INAUDIBLE] initialization.
And you have to remember that
the bias of the [INAUDIBLE]
should be initialized to 1.
These type of best
practices that you really
need to follow if you want
training to go smoothly.
And one key
principle of Keras is
that best practices
are included,
so every Keras layer has
well-optimized default
configuration that takes
into account all these best
practices.
So you can't just rely on Keras
defaults to be a good defaults
and to just get your model
to train out of the box
without requiring you
to fine-tune every
of these hyperparameters.
So best practice is
included, and you should just
care about only specifying
a few key parameters,
like the number of units, and
everything else should just
work right out of the box.
So for the question
encoder, it's even simpler.
We just have three lines.
First, we specify the input
tensor for the question.
So every question would
just be a sequence
of at most 100 integers.
So we will be limited to a
question at 100 words long.
And then we embed every
integer into word vector.
We have this embedding layer.
Note that we use masking on
this embedding layer, which
means that, for
instance, if we do
[INAUDIBLE] on our
questions, which
means that, if the questions
are shorter than 100 words,
we will just pad the rest
with zeros to get to 100.
This creates a
mask, which will be
propagated to the [INAUDIBLE]
layer right after that.
And so we finally encode
the sequence of four vectors
into a single vector
via another LSTM layer.
So note that, when we're using
these pre-trained inception
network, it's
absolutely fundamental
to be loading these
pre-trained weights
because you're dealing with
a fairly small data set.
And this set alone would
not have enough data
to allow you to learn to extract
interesting visual features.
So you really need to make
this network actually train.
You really need to be leveraging
these pre-trained weights.
And so finally this is how you
end up with the answer word.
You are taking the video
vector and the question vector.
You are concatenating them
with just a concat operation.
And finally, you are applying
a couple of dense layers,
and you're ending
up with 1,000 units.
So we'll have a vocabulary
of possible answers
that is just 1,000
different words.
And here's a step where
you're specifying the training
configuration of your network.
So you're just
instantiating a model, which
is a container for
a graph of layers,
and you're instantiating
them by just
specifying what are the
inputs of the model, what
are the outputs.
You can add any number of inputs
and any number of outputs.
And you are telling
the model that it
should use the ad
optimizer during training
and this last [INAUDIBLE].
You can notice that, when
specifying our classification
layer with 1,000 units, we did
not specify any activation.
So it's actually a
purely linear layer.
The softmax activation will
be included with the loss.
And so to sum up this entire
code, it's just about 15 lines.
So it's very, very short.
So we are essentially turning
this very complex architecture,
including loading
pre-trained weights,
into just a handful of lines.
So really reducing
complexity and by allowing
you to rely on different
configurations for every layer,
we're already reducing
cognitive load.
You don't have to
care about most
of the parameters of your
LSTM layer, for instance.
And the best part of
it, the most magic part,
is that, because this
implementation of Keras
is built from the ground
up for TensorFlow,
it's fully compatible with
things like estimators
and experiments.
So in just one line, you
can instantiate a TensorFlow
experiment.
And this gives you access
to distributed training
to train on Cloud ML and so on,
and also access to TensorFlow
serving.
So in just a few lines, you can
start running your experiment
as you did with your
question answering model,
reading your viewer data and
question data and answer data
from [INAUDIBLE] data frame.
You can start running
it on [INAUDIBLE]
in just a few lines.
So what you should take away
from this talk is very simple.
We are taking the Keras API.
We are bringing it
into TensorFlow.
It's a new implementation of
Keras built from the ground up
for TensorFlow.
And this gives you, as a
Keras user, more flexibility.
You can start
mixing and matching
pure TensorFlow functionality
with your Keras model.
As a TensorFlow user, this gives
you access to the full Keras
API to make your life easier.
And so you can expect these
Keras compatibility modules
to exist as
tf.contrib.keras by TF 1.1.
And finally, tf.keras
in TensorFlow 1.2.
And so we believe
this is a big step
towards making TensorFlow
and deep learning
accessible to everyone.
So that's it for me.
I believe, next, we
have some snacks.
Thank you for listening.
[MUSIC PLAYING]